[Music]
we are going live
we should be broadcasting
to several thousand people
out on the internet and all different
places in all different locations
in the known universe and it
is a great great pleasure to have two of
my friends
actually the man who gave me my start in
podcasting
during pandemic podcasting dr michael
shermer
who has uh influenced me and set me up
my initial interviews a year and a half
ago almost
when i started my pandemic podcast
journey with his book giving the devil
his due
michael is a professor he's the
publisher of skeptic magazine he's a
noted skeptic
an avid cyclist an all-around
all-around good guy and um i look i look
forward to
chatting more and learning from you
professor shermer how are you today
well uh well given the alternatives yes
life is good
and on my uh on my left on the screen at
least
is dr eric weinstein who is no stranger
to the into the impossible
podcast we have been together for many
many uh
decades it feels like but it's uh but
it's been less than that and
also coming up on our anniversary or our
youtube first conversation this i think
is our ninth one
so uh so it's great to have you too as
well dr weinstein how are you today
um great to be here thanks for having me
very interesting uh also to be with my
friend michael shermer
um i really am glad to uh
have this crew assembled for this topic
so uh what's so interesting to me is
there's sort of this phrase in german
the germans have the best
words for everything michael knows that
better than anybody i'm sure
uh but uh but they have words for
everything like ambulance the word for
ambulance eric do you know what the word
for ambulance is in german
no i just know that exit is also fought
yes i think the word for ambulance
michael can confirm is
crank wagon so you know if you're sick
you get hit
you go to the cranker wagon and uh but
one of the other things they have is
zeitgeist the spirit of the times and it
seems like right now we're in an
interesting age
where people are kind of uh being
affected
by this notion that there may be
extraterrestrial visitors
it may be other factors contributing to
a rash of sightings that have been
popular in the news media
and i thought we would kind of discuss
it today in a friendly debate
and and and really hash out some of the
issues on the skeptic side as michael
shermer
eric is coming from a side i think of
curiosity
and of great interest in particular in
some of the
uh second order implications of these
of these sightings if true and if not
true so i think i think it's quite
interesting
that when you guys are both able to join
me hang on here
as a guy who never talked about ufos
ever because i
deeply detested the topic up until april
of last year
i think we have three skeptics and three
open-minded people i don't want to put
anyone
yeah i agree i concur all right well i i
can't really say that i concur them
because look at this is one of my air
tags
that i got from apple and you can see
the symbol on it maybe it'll focus
it's a there it is
i'm not a skeptic and don't forget brian
you're
you're the one that did the cover story
of in the beginning
you rewrote genesis so uh what does that
say
that's right so i was talking
um about this uh for you know several
weeks i've been
having a lot of individuals on the
podcast ranging from
uh debunker famous debunker mick west
who may be watching he sent me a
question
to ask of eric uh seth shawstak i've
been on other podcasts my friend jeremy
reese who runs alien scientist
uh that podcast and kind of fleshing out
the implications if true
i've talked to the pilots involved in
some of the encounters that have been in
the message in the
in the media but i want to ask you do
you guys see something else some other
reason why
this particular moment this particular
issue is
uh so much in people's forebrains i'll
start with eric
why is this issue taken whole not not
the alien or whatever you know you want
to say but
this issue as an issue itself why is it
so important why is it so popular why is
it so
um such in demand for for people to
discuss
well i think it's been forced on us
which many of us resent
uh i think that the idea of um
i don't even know how to put this but
i've been able to avoid
ufos sasquatch remote viewing
uh esp my entire life with relative ease
and when our government takes a position
that makes it impossible to avoid that
by hiding its data
and making provocative statements
involving a thermonuclear
narrative you know the thermonuclear
threat did not disappear with the cold
war
and it is fashionable to treat it as if
it is a solved
problem of our past when it will be a
problem throughout
any future we might hope to have
i come with an unfun
curmudgeonly get off my lawn perspective
that you don't mess around with
thermonuclear
narratives and i think it's wonderful
that
you know the internet generation uh
feels so secure
that we can have fun with giant bug-eyed
aliens and
you know skinwalker ranch and cattle
mutilations but
when you actually are talking about
things probing your airspace or
areas in which military presence is
found
you're talking about something that
potentially could lead to a
conflagration
and so you know just the way i don't
expect
people to be
you know singing popular songs in church
i don't really enjoy narratives about
ufos
in military airspace so i think it's
really important to recognize
that we have now been taken by the new
york times by the pentagon
into a very weird place where our
scientists don't seem to have any data
there are a tiny number of videos all of
which seem to me to be rather low
quality
there's some anecdotal reports and
there's enough
claimed behind the scenes to warrant a
change
indicating that we were either lying
before lying now
um but whatever it is we've been putting
a tremendous amount of pressure on
people
not to report things apparently that
they see because they don't want
we don't want career ending behavior in
pilots
this is one of the few issues that i've
never been able to
fit any curve through the points
normally the problem is you can fit too
many curves through a set of points then
you have to discriminate
between which is a likely narrative and
which is a less likely narrative
i got nothing at the moment i don't know
any story that i can tell
um in which it makes sense what we're
doing either we've become incompetent
we've become bored
uh we're being visited by something that
would be the story
of the millennium or
we've been leapfrogged every single
narrative
uh goes to some place that makes
i think what we're trying to fit is a
sheet that is too small
on a mattress that is too large and
every time we get one corner
of the fitted sheet onto the mattress
another one pops off so i've never seen
anything like this
and it has beaten me in the sense that i
don't have a story that i can tell
michael when you look at this issue do
you see
you know other narratives besides the
you know simplest occam's like
explanation do you see other narratives
media driven
or you know popular um you know pop
science driven
what do you see as bringing this to the
forefront of the
of popular culture 60 minutes and every
newspaper in america
and baited breath and what do you
attribute that to
yeah so having some institutional memory
here helps this something similar
like to this happened in the early 1990s
you know we founded skeptic magazine 92
and the roswell incident was all the
rage and
there was a lot of pressure on the
government to issue a statement
what really happened and uh all the way
up to president clinton when
you know when he was president said all
right i will look into it
and uh and then finally in 1995 the the
government
issued pentagon issued a report on
roswell
in which they said okay that stuff back
in the 1950s when we said it was a
weather balloon
they're referring to this crash debris
at mac brazil's
ranch outside of roswell new mexico you
can see pictures of it online
it looks like balsa wood and tin foil
and and so forth
and they said okay it wasn't a weather
balloon like we said it was this high
altitude surveillance balloon
listening for the acoustic signatures of
uh nuclear explosions in the upper
atmosphere because we thought that's
what the soviets might have been doing
so that's what crashed then they offered
other details you know well what about
the alien bodies that some people
said that they saw and well those were
some other experiments we were doing
these high altitude balloon
tests where we would heave a crash test
dummy out
of the balloon at 90 000 feet just to
see what happens
and so maybe the people saw the crash
dummies
uh being hauled away by the military
that kind of thing
so there was a lot of excitement and
build up to this report like oh my god
oh my god they're going to tell us what
really happened and then when they told
us
none of the ufologists said oh okay now
we're satisfied
and uh we'll you know we'll go home and
work on something else no no
they just figured the government is
still lying so whatever the report
is going to be released later this month
if at all uh it's
i'm predicting it's not going to say but
anything particularly
uh revelatory about uh super advanced
drones that the russians have or
alien visitations or anything like that
and ufologists will not be satisfied
with it because
you know short of them saying yes it's
aliens and
we have the bodies they're in area 51
and we have a camera you can go live
and see it yourself and they won't be
satisfied
so uh i think eric's got it perfectly uh
said it perfectly well uh that it's
being forced on us
that is a commentary on the uh sort of
the media landscape
you know when the when the new york
times you know the paper of record
all the news that's sit fit the print
you know the gray lady says
ufos are real then of course everybody
has to
you know take notice but let's
deconstruct that for a minute now
this wasn't a a report
in the new york times uh conducted an
investigation conducted by
new york times journalists that are you
know go sent out by their bureau chief
to look into something
two of the three authors of that 2017
paper are ufologists
leslie keane wrote a best-selling book
called ufos uh you know pilots and
and generals go on the record the second
author blumenthal
wrote a book on alien abductions it was
a very positive
uh report about um the whole uh
1980s and early 1990s alien abduction
uh narratives that were recounted
um you know in breathless tones of like
you know it's
here it's real it's true and so this is
you know this is not a
a dis interested report by investigative
journalists
it's it's an article by believers and
so it's astonishing to me that people
seem to miss that and and
all the way up to last week or today you
know real that word real is doing a lot
of work in those
headlines you know finally the
government the pentagon says
they're real they mean the videos the
videos that have been passed around
since 2007
and they keep getting released like oh
there's new videos they're not new
they're the same videos that get
recycled over and over and finally the
pentagon said okay look they're not fake
they're real videos they were actually
shot by navy jets they're not made
by some um uh you know hacker in a
in in a basement with his laptop or cgi
in some hollywood studio
they're actual videos okay that's all it
means but the problem is is that when
people hear real their brains
autocorrect to
extraterrestrial the government has said
aliens are real
no that isn't what they said nobody is
saying that right
and that's the problem and eric's right
this
how can you ignore it yeah 60 minutes oh
my god
how can you ignore that all right well
we're done here you guys are both in
agreement this is a boring debate
thank you all good night no i'm just
great but
one of the things that bothered me most
and i think scientists are
to blame and i think the military is to
blame but most of all i think the media
is to blame as i'll explain in a second
the you know the topic comes up in the
new york times in the recent headline
pentagon you know or
navy can't rule out this but they can't
prove that either and
you know this is like unfalsifiable
hypotheses you know and
with no discriminatory no sensitivity
and then the other hand you have
you have pilots like uh commander fravor
and again
i have you know less courage in my
entire body than he has in this little
cuticle over here
uh but isn't that part of the problem he
says things like you can't you know
criticize it because if you're not a
fighter pilot if you don't know what a
cap point is
if you don't know what a thread vector
is um or he says you don't know how to
operate a fleer camera
on one hand on the other hand we as
scientists and we're all trained here at
different
uh different branches of science and or
social science
and the point being how do we how do we
communicate to the public
that no you don't have to be a pilot to
uh to say something about
uh about a phenomenon and the viability
of something
as a phenomenon a physicist can do that
likewise you don't have to be a
physicist to speculate on
the existence of of of perhaps sightings
eyewitness testimony
etc so you know michael i think it's i
think it's a it's an interesting
time and i keep asking who's benefiting
from this when you have a headline
that's like you know
um you know unicorns could exist they
can't be ruled out either you know my
daughter you know likes to
claim that there's an invisible unicorn
and the proof is that he visits her room
every night that there's no residue of
their unicorn ever found or discovered
when i go in a room
so the absence of evidence as our friend
carl sagan and my listeners will will
hate me if i don't
put up a sock puppet to that finger
puppet but you know absence of evidence
isn't necessarily evidence of absence
but nevertheless we're in this narrative
now where people are being asked to
speculate on the nature of what
scientific proof
constitute you know is constituted by
and and getting scientists to say things
like well science never proves anything
i mean it's very diff it's a very
dangerous time to be in on the other
hand
i can't say anything because i didn't
have the courage to put on the uniform
so where do we go where do we where did
we make an impasse
past this impasse eric i'm slightly
worried that we've mis-framed the
problem that i think we've
we've got the portion that we all agree
on right
and can we all agree that the videos to
an untrained observer
i think all three of us are untrained
observers i mean i don't know if you
could train for this but
um don't seem very impressive
is that is that a fair statement michael
totally yeah yeah impressive
they're weird they're weird but they're
not like
super high resolution with
you know data at the infrared
um you know optical thermal radar blah
blah blah
and okay so put that to one side
the concern is that many of us are
hearing
a great deal more from other sources
that are not usually
i don't know unreliable people who i've
known who i've
tracked their history people are
reaching out
and the claim that i don't know how to
evaluate
is that there's a great deal more it's
higher resolution
it's actually data rather than sort of
video anecdote
it appears that none of our top
scientists have access
to this at an official level they may
have secret access to it but
i certainly can tell you that i've poked
around in
you know differential geometry general
relativity and quantum field theory
which would be
three places i would want to to consult
if i thought that i was being visited
from another dimension another part of
the galaxy or that there was a major
breakthrough that allowed
um alien civilizations to visit us
easily or even our own future selves
what have you
and that's the data that really i find
fascinating
it's not it's not that look these videos
you know to the extent that they're
actually just
straight up videos of something
they certainly seem weird i'm not i'm
not i'm not claiming that
that it's nothing but i don't think i've
ever said the words fravor
or tic tac or nimitz or any of these
things
during the entire discussion which i've
been relatively focused on
not because um
well because i don't think that's where
the story is i think that the story
is the pentagon authenticating
the existence of a program i'm i'm
plugging in i'm seeing
all of these papers um you know like 38
papers
they seem to be from relatively obscure
academics
for the most part there seems to be a
ufo community that has security
clearances there seem to be
top physicists who don't know nothing
about this i mean
i think brian and i surprised lee smolin
who didn't even know that there was any
change in the ufo narrative recently
when we were on a live podcast with him
and all of this i find
to be the it is the data the data is the
absolutely
pathologically bizarre disconnect
between what appears to be the strength
of what has been released and
authenticated
with what is being claimed with the
extent to which things are being hidden
and the absence of any adults in the
defense complex or the intelligence
community
to shut down what seems to be
some sort of arguable fever dream
on the part of people who desperately
want to meet aliens now i would say i
desperately want to meet aliens
but not so desperately that i don't have
other things to do on this planet if
there are no aliens to be met
and so my question is where's my goddamn
data
so michael to that extent when you have
multiple reports from multiple pilots
these are trained professionals great
costs great sacrifice to our country
um even if there's you know the type two
error probability is small
you know that might be a a false a false
negative it could be a false positive
but you know don't we have an obligation
to investigate
all you know to protect our pilots uh at
some level
don't we have an obligation as eric says
this is our data
i mean you and i you know have a right
to see what what's
what data are being promulgated and by
the way you put a lot of faith michael
for a skeptic in the efficacy of our of
our pentagon
to and our military apparatus to be both
transparent
and accountable and i think the lessons
of the last 15 months should have
disabused all of us of that notion so
what do you say about not to mention the
not to mention the lessons of wiki
wikileaks and all the way back to the
pentagon papers 50 years ago this week
uh well so one of the most revealing
statements by the pilot
one of the pilots on 60 minutes was that
he sees these things
every day and bill whittaker the
journalist for 60 minutes says
what every day he goes oh yeah every day
like it's a common occurrence okay if
that's true
what else should be true what else
should be true is we should have
thousands
of high resolution high definition clear
photographs and videos of whatever these
things are
shot by passengers on commercial
jetliners people sitting at the beach
you know there's a hundred million or
more
uh you know uh cell phone smartphones
with high
resolution cameras on them you know we
should have tons of videos and and yet
as
eric points out we have a handful of
these grainy blurry
videos i've been in the ufo business for
30 years
they're all you know grainy blurry it's
i'm almost beginning to think the aliens
are just blurry that's just what they
look like
you know the ufos are blurry that's part
of their stealth technology they're
controlling us
they're trolling us that way so
and it's not to say that um you know
pylons aren't trained and
but they're not immune to the normal
perceptual misperceptions that we all
have
misperceiving the size or speed of
something at a distance when you're
moving
it's dark whatever you'll see these
reports like one in
um leslie keane's book on ufos uh of
where
you know you know the pilot uh gives
this description you know the craft is
150 feet long and it's traveling 350
miles an hour
how do you know i mean this is and there
was no radar uh
measurements of this this is just his
visual sight
okay this is very difficult to to take
seriously without some corroborating
measurements
now to your first point that the pilots
are corroborating either each other or
their
visual reports with what was seen on
radar
on the ship or something okay that
confirms what the pentagon
said when they said they're real that is
to say something out there
is being filmed it's not just an
artifact of
inside the lens like a lens flare for
example the history of ghosts and
haunted houses is is fraught with lens
flares
okay just the the light is bouncing
around inside the
series of lenses in a 35 millimeter uh
camera
so it's not that it's obviously
something else okay but but but what
and you know to his credit you know mick
west did the heavy lifting on this by
you know kind of looking at each of
those videos like the one you're showing
now
and looking at what those numbers around
the edge
of the frame mean you know i don't know
what they mean and you know
most of us looking at have no idea and
you know mick looked it up
well presumably someone in the pentagon
or the navy or whoever
knows exactly what every one of those
numbers means why aren't they telling us
okay it's not actually shooting off to
the left at a high rate of speed
the zoom is going from one to two this
is one of the things that mick
pointed out i think this is the one
there where you see it says one
and then if you go forward a little bit
it it jumps to two
so the image is is blowing up twice as
is as big which means the object is
going to move
suddenly there it's about to go to the
left and you know why is it that
it's mick west has to figure this out
for us why didn't the pentagon go out
and go
guys guys calm down this is nothing
zooming off anywhere
this is not anti-gravity technology this
is not a chinese russian super secret
drone it's the zoom on the camera all
right presumably if they issue a report
they would at least
do what mick west has done for us yeah
and i want to point out i did
have been in contact with alex dietrich
as lieutenant commander at lieutenant
junior grade at the time of the incident
uh and actually
mick had her on their on her on his
podcast yesterday
i want to point that out that she's
incredibly gracious
she has you know she's she's talked a
lot about this and i think
you know her recollections you know
there are discrepancies between her and
favor
i don't think that's particularly
germane to what her argument is you know
she wants to make it less
of of a taboo for pilots to come forward
as do i i want our
military men and women who are as i say
a million times braver than i am
to have the best equipment the best
training and the best protection against
threats uh like this but eric um i want
to get go back to to your
your take uh on this so when absent
these videos
you know in the new york times i feel
that there is only one
institution that stands to benefit
you've done a lot with the gated
institutional narrative promotion you
coin those
and i think in this case there's only
one clear-cut winner and it is
the media and the media have a vested
interest in making the story
persist as long as possible even in the
old gray lady that prints all the news
fit to print
and we know how accurate they are they
never make mistakes they never have any
political agendas whatsoever right guys
so my question is
how can we be possibly being manipulated
in some sense again uh by by media
forces that
jeff bezos owns the washington post uh
has no profit motive
necessarily anymore his infinite money
can shovel into it has to do with space
maybe it's interesting for his space
missions who knows but the bottom line
is you know these things in the
washington post from the washington post
to
the new york times uh they go
unquestioned or we don't report them 60
minutes shows
one side only and doesn't report the uh
the
the scientist perspective or a skeptic's
perspective
and they oh afterwards um 60 minutes
overtime see what they said when they
landed back on the carrier deck
so how do you balance this against cui
bono eric you know and
and and again the nancy kerrigan
question i always ask you why now
why here why us
well um
okay so i'll play tanya harding to your
nancy kerrigan
i don't want to do that yet we're not at
the cui bono question because almost
certainly
the media is going to be humiliated for
taking this seriously if
the strength of this is what
is all that we're seeing i mean i really
i don't i had an interaction with mick
west the other day on twitter
which if if i had to describe it it was
sort of like
white to move in mate in five and the
claim was
the story is fantastically interesting
no matter what
it's a very branched decision tree much
the way you'd have in a chess
problem where lots of things can move
but every single way
of resolving the story resolves to
something fascinating
so so actually he has a question for you
mick has a question for you that he
um well let me let's not let mick drive
the bus unless he wants to come on the
show right now you can ask it to me
later i don't i'm not afraid of it but
i won't like to continue my my line of
thinking
mick effectively you can grant him all
sorts of
you know a rook a bishop a queen
you know yes i i don't find these videos
particularly compelling yes
maybe pilots are starved for attention
yes maybe some of it is bokeh
and yes maybe the camera turning very
quickly would have the illusion of
something speeding off
etc etc seat at all
assume that in fact there is a group of
escapees from marin county deep in wu
who have taken over a pentagon narrative
about
military air space uh in order to amuse
themselves and uh you know effectively
this is a burning man camp
uh gone out of control that's a huge
story
it's a really big deal and
it doesn't really matter in some sense
whether
the former paper of record uh turned
i don't know institution that isn't has
inscrutable motives
we all know that the new york times has
slid downhill at an incredible level
we're in a highly politicized era people
are desperate for funding they're
desperate for excitement they can't find
meaning in their lives blah blah blah
blah
we are still a thermonuclear nation and
we need
bad narratives reigned in because we're
we are not
even in a bipolar situation we're in a
multi-polar situation
it is simply uh if if michael shermer's
best explanation were true or if mick
west's best explanation is true
we've had a massive collapse if we are
at the level in which we are talking
about
incentives that one part of the pentagon
wants money that another part of the
pentagon has or
people are squabbling and there's no one
to lower the boom
and say cut it out this is an extremely
serious
situation what it's what it means to be
in the military you guys
don't get it we can't afford this i just
i don't think that any of this really
resolves the basic puzzle we have we've
been
starved for the data there appear to be
i
i just checked today with a friend of
mine who i believe
is uh luella zondo's attorney dan
sheehan
who i've been following since the iran
contra
um you know scandal we did the pentagon
papers
uh a storied famous attorney um
i checked with many things that he
wished to say
i said that i would keep them all in
confidence he said i didn't have to keep
them in conference
by the way michael you you should know
that you are the of the three of us most
likely to be an alien because you seem
blurry to my uh
to my weight right it's coming from the
past
michael's calling from people are saying
how do you still have those aol compact
discs
but don't be cruel to those of us over
50.
um the thing i'm i'm just shocked by
is is that we can't actually have a
conversation we keep getting distracted
because we don't have the language that
says you have to you have to integrate
over the entire decision tree
you nobody can say that it's aliens and
what was represented to me just and i
checked before i came on the podcast
is that in essence
all what was represented is that all
plausible explanations um
appear to have been ruled out that's a
claim i'm not saying it's true
i'm saying that it's a claim there's
also a claim that there's a vast amount
more
data and it is much higher quality that
it hasn't been down
down sampled it hasn't been degraded so
as to preserve
um you know military secrets i don't
know how to evaluate it because i'm not
saying i'm not being lied to i'm not
saying that people are not themselves
confused
what i am saying is that people are not
representing the problem correctly and
if you set up the problem in any
one of various ways i can set it up so
that either
absolutely this is a funding dispute
that got out of control
where people were trying to have some
fun and uh you know and
it became this international story or i
can set it up in a different way in
which basically
we know it's aliens and we just can't
say that the final words
and what i asked dan sheehan today was
are we at the point in your opinion or
in the opinion of people who
came out of the pentagon's atip program
that the only the is the explanation for
why no one will say it's
aliens that all of the remaining
branches of the decision tree that we
can think of have career-ending pos
uh implications and i thought that that
was a pretty good way of grouping
the set of things like you know it's
atlantis or
orcas developed opposable fins or were
being visited from other dimensions or
these are future humans going back in
time along closed time like curves or
any one of the things that would
sort of get get you a trip to the
nuttery
are those what's left and the answer
came back
to me and i and i hoped in if if i i
think i
i got this straight so uh i will
apologize if i didn't understand it the
dan's
answer was yes that's what's left
now does that mean that dan knows dan
wasn't
part of atip he's a lawyer
does that mean that atip understands
this maybe not
maybe they're a bunch of crazy
enthusiasts i don't really understand
what a ufology
i just found out that ufology is a word
that's how backwards i am on this topic
um no no i am late as late can be to
this party
this has had zero interest to me i think
we are not representing the weirdness of
the story accurately
if we're already at quibona but if we
isolated just to the pentagon i mean you
could think of many different
internecine
type squabbles from military fighter jet
competitions
to inter-agency squabbles like the
space force air force now these are all
navy pilots and one narrative i've heard
is this is
you know kind of par for the course and
navy's has the last gasps that
attempting to get the high frontier
under its control before
space force and the air force kick in
this is typically the purview
of air force uh these are space space
activities if indeed that's the case
what is typically the purview of the air
force uh activities and
external to our planet if indeed these
are ufos and so forth
coming from other other advanced
technological civilizations
maybe i'm i'm just missing it but i'm
being reached out to by
various people i have contacts that i
didn't cultivate for this purpose i've
tried to check in on
what i am hearing and again what i am
hearing
is not data and that's just hearsay
does not strike me as having any analog
in my previous
life i've never seen my the closest i've
ever seen
been to a ufo sighting is in 1988
i was lying on a pier with
my now wife then girlfriend looking up
at the stars
on lake waban and there was a light in
the sky that appeared to be a satellite
of the space station i pointed it out it
had a beautiful
very clean arc as if it was in orbit
and then it reversed and it was it
appeared to be
a very point like source very very
distant
i didn't understand how something like
that could do it
could could do that move i couldn't
figure it out
but i haven't spent 30 years obsessed
with the point of light that i couldn't
figure out why it did the thing that it
did
it was just like anomalously weird and
you know look i've been known to tipple
occasionally and
you know look hey she was she was good
looking so you know maybe maybe i was
just
moved by the moment um but i really
i don't have this part of my
soul unquenched i don't need ufos to
have a meaningful existence
i don't think we're listening i think
that what we're being told repeatedly
from multiple sources
is that these are daily occurrences in
many cases there are two basic loci
that seem to crop up over and over again
off the east coast i guess
around virginia north carolina and some
locus of activity off the coast of
southern california
um i guess there's a few mexican islands
in baja
and san diego and i'm not quite sure
why we're having trouble saying
that the data is weirdly the withheld
claims that appear to be fairly
consistent from very different people
and the otherwise inexplicable behavior
of people who respond when queried
um in a profound way i i've just never
encountered
this before but you're computing you
know potentially impugning
you know or pointing to a monumental
security
you know vulnerability in our pentagon
at the highest level
you know as michael said there are
people i think he's even a friend of
ours who's
or at least twitter friends as close as
i can get to a real friend these days
uh and and that is you know people who
are reporting daily
incident sightings so that is a
falsifiable hypothesis so fly out there
oh it wasn't there today okay
we'll come back tomorrow it wasn't there
tomorrow we're reporting very different
things the tic tac is
unique it's suey generous there's
nothing like it then there are
other things balls and spheres and
sphere or spheres and
boxes and and so forth what's that
i heard a new one over the mediterranean
from the same source
about we were going at incredible speeds
in our fighters and suddenly
and you know i had to make sure that i
was parsing the sentence accuracy
somebody said that circles were being
flown around are fighters
at very high speed and i said you mean
that
something appeared to be flying much
better because the colloquy
you know to run circles around means uh
you know to do much better than
i said no literally uh this is what was
occurring now
i keep trying to push on all of this
stuff and
it doesn't resolve one way or the other
so in general my feeling about this is
that this is an invitation for the
scientific and the skeptical communities
to destroy themselves
by not setting the problem up and not
saying
give us the damn data because we don't
know what we're talking about the major
data we have right now is withheld
uh is a narrative involving withheld
information that is the data
and you know i just i don't understand
the passion for david fravor the tic tac
the nimitz
the the the the pyramids you know is it
bokeh is it this is
uh this this should leave us cold the
key
issue are the consistent widespread
allegations without the condemnation
of the pentagon that this is an
irresponsible narrative dangerous to the
security of the nation that provides the
world's
responsible use of force michael what do
you make of eric's claims you know
the meta issue here that has to be
addressed is
what does this say even if it's
not true as he's stipulating let's say
all these are fake but then you're
getting these reports what is this
saying about the
the you know our integrity of our of the
of the high command of the
of the agencies that are sworn and put
on the uniform and as alex says you know
raises her right hand to protect us
are they often you know off the ranch
here or
you know is that something is it
basically you know eric is imputing
you know perhaps malice i think more
incompetence and i'd like to get your
take on it
yeah well a couple of things first of
all we uh it is good to remember that
the branches of the military
do compete with one another for funding
uh
and uh you know budgets and so forth
i've been
i've been reading quite a few books on
um the
arms race during the cold war the cuban
missile crisis
the history of the bomb and so on and
you know a couple things that came clear
in fred kaplan's book the bomb and
martin sherwin's book uh
the on apocalypse let's see it's called
uh
gambling with armageddon on the um
missile crisis is that the the real arms
race was not between the u.s and the
ussr it was between the army navy and
air force
and each of them wanted uh the bomb
because they could get more funding
and this is why we have a triad we have
a triad because the navy said well we
want a bomb so we got to put in our
submarines
and the air force said well we want a
bomb so we have them in our bombers and
the army said well we want a bomb so we
have missiles
that's why we have a triad so basically
it tripled the
overall military budget just on that
alone and uh you know it's staggering
that that
was far more competitive than that we
were competing against the russians
there never was a missile gap when
kennedy ran against nixon
uh while eisenhower was finishing up his
term there was this whole thing about
the missile gap between us and the
in the soviet union it it that that
never existed
that was only in the minds of you know
politicians and so
that's a concern so whatever it is we're
talking about here
we should keep in mind that the for the
forces do compete with one another
for claims on things that are going on
especially as it affects their budgets
um i i um in terms of
why this interest well how could you not
be interested if it was true
that we're being visited by aliens of
course that would be
the discovery of the century if not of
all time
and uh and so let's put that off on one
side and then say well what's the other
hypothesis
they're super advanced russian or
chinese assets
but somehow that they've gotten decades
or centuries ahead of us technologically
and without us knowing you know i make
the case in that
quilette article i did that this is just
not how history of science and
technology evolves you know it's very
incremental everybody knows what
everybody else
is doing they all scientists and
technologists read each other's journals
uh nations steal each other's secrets
and so on and so forth the manhattan
project the most secret project of all
time
in our country uh the russians had all
everything we knew within four years
they stole it and
you know apple and all these uh tech
companies you know they have super
secure
uh systems and and uh protect their
property rights
through lawsuits and so on and yet all
cell phones and computers are
roughly within six months of each other
in terms of development
so the chances that whatever we're
looking at are
super advanced chinese or russian assets
that we just
just don't know about is is pretty slim
so what does that leave us with two
things one it's the kind of things that
mick west is talking about you know
camera motion
uh distance uh distortions the movement
of the cameras and
zooms and things like this or
anomalies we just can't explain and you
know
so this is called the residue problem
there's always a residue of unexplained
anomalies
that no current scientific theory can
account for 100
of observations so what do you do with
that well
i don't know we just live with it or we
wait for the pentagon
somebody knows i i think in my opinion
somebody knows and they're just
you know why they're not telling us i
don't know mike michael let me just ask
you a question
you and i had a friendly skeptic on
skeptic
knife fight on twitter and
oh yeah that's right right and
my claim was that's not how innovation
works
innovation works sometimes you have an
incremental aspect
to what has been learned or understood
but it may unlock what appears to be
discontinuous power
and so you know i put the problem with
you
that um you've proven that renaissance
technologies
on long island doesn't exist because
we have a secretive hedge fund that has
maintained an advantage over every other
investment system known to man that
cannot
be easily related you know if the idea
is that it's not actually a hedge fund
uh
i think that's a fascinating idea we
know that there are
um you know i gave the example of
uh herod sato in table tennis who was
the one who figured
out that if you put uh rubber on both
sides of a sandpaper bat
um it muffled the sound and he was able
to be the worst player on the japanese
team who won the entire world the table
thomas
champ championship in bombay bob
beeman's long jump
he did something on that one particular
jump that produced an outcome that
wasn't a few millimeters difference but
you know just an unimaginable flop
right well that was the same olympics in
mexico city and
i i don't need to tell you that eddie
van halen
and jimi hendrix both represented a
complete discontinuity in both cases
people got a chance to understand what
they were doing but
generally speaking i would say that
nobody's really figured out what
generates
the majesty of jimi hendrix i don't
think that what you're saying is
accurate not because
the input may not move incrementally
for the most part but that the
consequence
of getting something a little bit better
may be an enormous difference and so i
asked if i recall correctly you were
citing matt ridley
how many years difference is 1900
or 1902 from 1952. in one case you don't
even have powered flight in the other
case you're dropping
fusion devices you know about neutrons
and antimatter
relativity quantum theory we're in a
situation in which if you think about
the early 20th century
i i noted that my friend and our mutual
friend sam harris
made the same thing the same claim about
tens of thousands if not you know
hundreds of thousands or millions of
years in the future um
no you can't tell how much more advanced
the civilization
is in that metric because
the amount of power that's unlocked need
not
be consonant with the discovery that
unlocked it
but i think you're you're missing one of
the points michael was making in that
tweet was that innovation
the fosberry flop it wasn't like people
stopped you know didn't adopt it
everybody adopted
it really quickly efficient market
thesis applied to technology and
michael's talking primarily about
about let me just finish the thought
michael's talking primarily
about it not being an adversary on earth
because in that case
you know they would be likely look the
chinese have yet the russians have let
we beat them to the moon
they have yet to send a man mission to
crude mission to the moon right
so if you look at it he's saying
innovation-wise not speculating about
the physics
of the 25th century visited upon us by
some distant galaxy like we would all be
quite thrilled to uh to witness but he's
saying it
ruling out the adversary let's take this
as a bayesian problem
so what kind of credence can you put on
eyewitness testimony it carries some
evidence michael was abducted at one
point
on his race across america he can talk
about that uh 1992 i believe he's
he's actually been abducted uh so we can
we can talk about it so eyewitnesses
uh we can put some bayesian uh prior on
that we can put on technology so
advanced they can get here but not
advanced enough that it can't evade uh
ages two radar uh et cetera and then you
could go through the list and how you
could maneuver in the earth's atmosphere
and why you'd want to go to a warning
area
off the coast of southern california but
not be spotted you know over
over the white house anyway you could go
through this whole list of things that
we could try to pre-game and
dunk and experiment until the until the
proverbial cows get mutilated no i hope
no cows would get mutilated by any of
these aliens
but the point i'm trying to make is the
the question if it's
if it's a physics problem you and i
could talk about it if it's a
sociological problem
you and michael can talk about it but if
it's a pentagon problem if it's a data
problem you keep saying
this is our data this is our data you
know we own nasa has
has as a hubble space telescope right so
i can show you data
now the hubble space telescope's data
i'll put it up on my screen right here
it's beautiful well that's not the data
i want to show i want to show
my firefly there we go what up there it
is
okay so there's the hubble deep field is
this data
as a scientist is this data it's very
weak data
but you actually have access to it you
can get you can you don't need a foia to
get this data
actually it's not a very weak data it
was it was it was constructed for a very
particular purpose and actually the data
relative to that
particular purpose is fairly compelling
no actually there's far more data
there's far more actual data that we
astronomers use
from the individual spectrum of the
individual luminosity the photometry the
the aperture
we can do a lot more with this data than
just look at it on screen savers
we're talking past each other the reason
for collecting
that as data i mean you and i agree i
think
as to what what you're saying but it's
the framing of it
we had this question if we look if we
tried to find the blankest part of the
blank sky
what would we find if we left the lens
open for a very long time for a long
exposure we were somewhat surprised that
relative to that question this is
actually very interesting data
to for a smattering of a different
questions
it's very very cute
that's right it's very weak data but
you know when i tried to make the point
that renaissance technologies
is a different paradigm because it
hasn't been copied it hasn't defused
um that's a different issue than the
fosberry
flop replacing the scissors you know
that was the previous high bar
maneuver and so in that situation uh
there was radically quick adoption i
mean
i find it very interesting for example
that um
nobody has bothered to uh just to ask
the question why do ashkenazi jews
over perform in physics
why do two countries uh overperform
in the boston marathon i think it was
before
was it 1967 and nobody from kenya or
ethiopia had ever won
and then those two nations completely
dominated the results
so you can say well that's the ability
to diffuse heat uh you know there's been
a
competing explanations there are
different
things that go against michael's
um broad claims based on the
assertions of matt ridley and michael is
a very reasonable guy we've talked
for a long time we're not trying to get
each other we're just trying to say
so eric let me addre let me address that
because
it's a good point let's let's say the
chinese have
a a lab let's say it's in wuhan and it's
next to that
viral lab and and they're not only
inventing viruses they're also inventing
uh you know super fast technology that
allows a jet to go faster than
uh this the speed of sound without
making a uh a sonic boom
something
yeah yeah yeah for sure okay that that's
possible that you know somehow our
scientists missed that
their scientists are not publishing in
the journals that our scientists would
read to see the incremental improvements
because they've been kept isolated by
their government something like that
um if that were true then of course i
don't think the pentagon is going to
tell us this
when they release this report you know
oh boy we [ __ ] up you know the chinese
got way ahead of us
uh in this one you know fell swoop in
the last five years and
so now we're going to copy their
technology and we promise
we'll catch up we just won't hear about
it um so
your hypothesis is possible but i don't
know how we can test it because
again that data is you know they're not
going to share that with us
and um and so that would be the only way
i could see that
that's possible because the diffusion
would happen pretty quickly after that
if that were the case
it reminds me of the scene in the movie
uh airplane
uh where they're trying to help land
this jet this is should we turn on the
runway light
and they say no that's just what they'll
be expecting so we're gonna starve our
own
scientists of the data that would be
necessary to keep pace with china right
what i'm trying to get is very different
none of these simplistic explanations
work
right you can't get rid of it by saying
that there are no secrets you can't
really get rid of it saying that there
are no permanent advantages you can't
get rid of it by saying that all
progress is incremental
every time somebody's asserted that i
think i've tried to be relatively
diligent and saying no here's a here's a
counter example here's a counter example
now if you said it's rare i'd appreciate
that
it's not that usual it's somebody to
something wholly discontinuous that
can't be copied etc etc
i don't think that's where we are and i
think
that it just it's very frustrating
because i i look at the number of
permanent clusters there's a cluster out
here of people who believe that china in
particular has zoomed ahead of us in
hypersonic technology
and that this is a closely guarded
secret and
that's the explanation there's another
group of people who believe
that we the us have lodged
secret knowledge inside of our aerospace
companies maybe
the glenn martin company in particular
who knows
where the secret knowledge is all about
technology it's not about physics
they're working with the same physics as
everybody else
there's a different group right which
claims this is a funding thing
it's a psyop it's the psyop i've i've
talked to each of these communities
none of these communities can answer all
of the questions that's my point
and and the problem that i answer all
the questions though eric is it
necessary to prove every
rule out every possible explanation for
ufo sighting by mick west or
does he just need one no no that's
i don't know why this is so confusing we
have
i would expect almost all of us
would go through all of the explanations
and say
i've noticed that every time i get these
three corners
on the mattress the fourth corner
doesn't get anywhere close
and the mattress is bowed in this really
unnatural shape
at some point you say i think i have a
twin size
fitted sheet for a queen size mattress
and that's what i'm trying to say i'm
trying to say that
i have a category which i can't explain
which is none of this makes any effing
sense
and the skeptics don't make sense the
bug
you know the the wild-eyed dreamers
don't make sense
every single thing i can run through
this doesn't add up and
what i keep hearing is can't i get back
to one of the positions that i i feel
like
you know it's propaganda it's fighting
it's infighting
it's people who don't understand the
difference between anecdote
it's social pressure that pilots
pressure each other
we've got a mystery and that's where we
are i mean
one so i have to because i said i would
um
our mutual friend mick west he asks you
a question suppose that robert bigelow's
a tip style
wu had started to seriously overlap real
issues like drone
airspace incursions and human equipment
identification limitations in other
words
the atip had exposed some weakness
that's vulnerable and real
how long uh could how could the pentagon
shut that down
before the report is released in other
words
do they do they have this i mean are you
are you really
you know overestimating how good the
pentagon is how monolithic they are
or are you more worried about them
having the keys to the
to the cadillac at you know at age 14
and
doing something extremely dangerous
potentially with it if i were the
pentagon
one thing i would do is i would come and
talk to me
and people like me very quickly and say
you're on team america right i'd say
you got it you got a big audience yeah i
guess i do
you're smart guy you've got a degree i
don't know the latter is true
we need to talk to you we need you to
understand that there's some real
sensitivities and we need your help
we need to get this that we need to get
the toothpaste back in the tube we need
to get the genie back in the bottle
because we've got real problems and
we've got a woo narrative intersecting
with a crazy narrative this is where i
got to with with mick before
which is isn't that a huge story now is
that a story that i would be willing
to keep quiet let me be entirely honest
i would keep that story quiet if the
issue
is that we had a really serious threat
we had a really garbagey narrative
yeah the pentagon were to reach out to
me i'm on team america
and i know what to do if you don't reach
out to me
i'm going to behave like every single
scientist
i'm going to try to set up the problem
try to figure out what i know what i
don't know what i believe what seems
anomalous
and my claim is that i hear silence
but i've reached out to by one or two
groups
i'm not going to say more
if what you're saying is that we have a
an overlapping problem of real drones
and
fake aliens somebody
has blown it in our
national science and our national
intelligence complex and they've got to
get their act together it's a big deal
why do you have more faith in their
ability to craft a media narrative
when we know the uh the plethora of
failures
in their own purview in their belly with
the f-35 lightning
trillions of dollars a project that is
still by all accounts completely
inadequate for the pilots that fly it
putting potential
of our brave men and women at risk
that's their job that's their day job in
other words
if you ask me brian you know why aren't
you good at crafting this narrative of
the media
when you go out that's not my job i'm a
professor of astrophysics at uc san
diego
you're you're faulting them are you
using that as sort of evidence
that that that the trains off the tracks
at
the pentagon when in reality they're not
even good at some of the things that
they've done
in terms of monitoring threats how about
this eric
we had a threat that they knew about in
20 and 20 19 20 20
and all i can hear about is oh it's
great the chinese can build a hospital
in nine days haha look at them
we should have known at that point i was
buying stuff on amazon
you know when i started to hear that
because i was like that's unusual why
are they building a hospital yeah
they're awful human you know treatment
of human beings
welding them in or doing whatever they
were reputed to do
but we have trillions of dollars in the
nsa and the pentagon the dod
why didn't we catch that how come how
come you're not more concerned about
that
what do you mean i mean i just put
myself at risk as a
noted xenophobe and racist for claiming
that
a wet market that does not appear to
sell bats
is an unlikely source and that the wuhan
institute of virology before john
stewart decided that the rest of us
could say what was obviously true
i'm very tired of these people and
at some point and i don't mean to be
rude uh you have to ask people with an
above 80 iq
for help and if you're not willing to do
that
then we are not in in possession of
we don't i i don't understand something
i i don't mean to be rude about it
but we developed the world's best
factory for producing
smart people out of ordinary human
beings
and i know those people those are my
friends they're your friends
and we've got a large number of them and
they're completely in the dark
they are so far as i can tell unless
they've all been taken
to um you know method acting school
and each one of them can put dustin
hoffman to shame
nobody bothered to wake the scientific
community
the idea of saying we're going to have a
manhattan project
by getting middle school teachers
together
in in the desert um and
make president powerpoint presentations
to each other is not what you do
you'd go call the institute for advanced
study first and foremost there were like
five guys if i were just to go one place
i'd go pick up and and brian you and i
thought about this before i'd pick up ed
whitt and robert dycraft
nema arcane hamed juan mao de santa and
natty cyber
just be before breaking a sweat i call
up jim simons and ask
uh for his help i would make sure
that i was talking to people who are
have domain expertise with respect to
general relativity particle theory
differential geometry
every time we get into this conversation
i hear about material science
and i say i really don't care that much
you know
at some level if it's just a change in
technology if somebody figured out
hypersonic technology fine i get it
but this has become completely crazy the
idea that we avoid
smart people at all costs we make sure
that there are no smart people on our
coveted narrative
there are no smart people in our physics
narratives there are no smart people in
our threats
this yes i i understand i'm stepping
into
the following bear trap eric you sound
elitist
no kidding look at the prosperity all
around you if you happen to live in an
advanced country you're welcome
now get the data to the smart people and
stop effing around
maybe they are just to be you know
devil's advocate as michael's written
about and his book
giving devils do behind me there uh just
a reminder around michael shermer he has
a
wonderful channel on this very uh
channel which will hopefully not get
banned or taken down anytime soon uh and
that is called skeptic so at skeptic and
eric weinstein has a channel as well i
put that in the show notes as well as
the proprietor of the portal podcast
with the pros of t
and the popping and i've got my good sr
uh 71 blackbird filter on top
of my ssl 2 microphone uh i'm brian
keating chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics at uc san diego and
the proprietor
of the into the impossible podcast but
eric
perhaps as a devil's advocacy method
uh perhaps the pentagon and these uh and
our rulers
they do know that this is actually
nothing to waste the time
and you remember you know paul of the
mathematician erdos
who was forced by his colleagues and
students to get off methamphetamines
for some period of time for a month in
the 1950s i believe it was
and at the end of the month he came to
his colleagues in the student's door and
he said
congratulations you've set back
mathematics exactly one month
now i'm wondering what if they know this
what if they know that there's nothing
there's no there there there's no there
there and then why waste edwin's time
your your friend
with the same initials although there's
only one ew that i care about
there are multiple ews we care about
edwin's an amazing person who i
don't think it was a very good steward
of the physics enterprise it's not the
issue
the issue is i mean i i don't know you
have to appreciate every day i get up
i look at the world the world is so far
shifted from what i expect i write about
it on twitter i used to do podcasts i
will do them again
the reason people listen to me is that
i'm perpetually just scratching my head
and saying what
did somebody let off a neutron stupid
bomb all over the all over the world now
we're having the craziest discussions
about narratives that make absolutely no
sense
we either have a significant threat or
we don't
if you have a significant threat you
hire the people you train the people you
go talk to them
in the 1950s for example we appeared to
have
two separate programs that were
dealing with anti-gravity and uh
involving uh two separate
philanthropists one of them worked
through an aerospace company in a
military air force base the other one
worked for the university system i
believe that the higgs mechanism
bizarrely came out of all of this stuff
you know we have dabbled in this before
i looked through the list of names on
this 38 papers of atip i don't know that
atip is the only thing that's been
tasked with you know understanding this
we are
not behaving as an advanced
technological society facing a genuine
mystery with military and safety
implications and i will
you know you will see people writing
things like wow eric goes on at great
length he says the same thing
um you know paul erdish wasn't that
important of a mathematician he was very
good but he was like a combinatorist he
wasn't
you're not talking about alexander
growth and deep you're not talking about
michael latia or ed whitton
i'm saying that we have people who would
i believe in general if we have real
data would go through this like the
night out like a knife through butter
now somebody in the comments said
something about
has eric never heard of the jason's well
one how badly degraded are the jasons uh
if you know that this is supposed to be
our super elite um
advising group i believe we tried to
shut them down because we can't figure
out why we still train
smart people we are behaving
like lunatics who built the society that
was able to build the blackbird to build
the bombs
to do all of the amazing things that we
do our chip factories
nobody in the private sector would put
up with this kind of avoidance
of scrutiny and one of the reasons that
it was
is least likely to be aliens as least
likely to be anything really exciting
is is that no one's scared enough to
make a trip to cambridge massachusetts
berkeley california princeton new jersey
hyde park illinois i don't know
i i just don't know how to think about
people who avoid
smart people and continually have
discussions about
nothing i mean look at these papers this
is not what we're supposed to be doing
okay devil's advocate back to what
michael said earlier which is you could
have made the same argument
back in 1949 michael richard feynman
needs to know about this this uh this
strange material this this uh found
crass
how come we're not talking to richard
feynman michael we were talking to
richard feynman about uf
uaps sorry when richard feynman tells
the amusing story about getting off
in north carolina at the airport and he
doesn't know which university to go to
and he says
to the cab driver you know the genius
richard feynman says
were people going to any university
saying gmu knew
and they said oh yeah that's unc chapel
hill well
that was bainsen institute
right something like the institute for
the study of physical fields uh extended
a position to bryce dewitt his wife
cecile
moritz dewitt uh that was about
antigravity and and you know it just it
bothers me
that nobody has david kaiser onto their
program
to know the history of this stuff he was
on this program talking just about that
and and he can look for a link to it why
do you think i come on this program i
mean
brian you're doing stuff that nobody
else is doing but what i'm trying to say
is
i call up mit and i call up david kaiser
and i say look
here's the history that i know you know
we're not talking to people i deal with
colleagues who believe that peer review
is
is an intrinsic part of science which is
clearly not true
the brainwashing of our scientific
institutions
the the fact that we don't know the
history of the golden age of general
relativity that we don't understand the
way in which antigravity
intersected the way that we don't
understand that we distributed programs
in the interstitial regions between
non-profits like universities
government agencies like units of the
military and private corporations like
our aerospace corporations
we used to know how things got done
and then we passed the mansfield
amendment in the late 1960s early 1970s
to put the kibosh on military funding of
civilian research
and we went completely insane i mean i
understand their motivation for not
wanting the military to be directing
civilian research during the vietnam war
but when you knock out a load-bearing
wall you are responsible for putting
some support in its place
before the destruction is complete
michael if you're in char
sorry uh by michael if you're in charge
of the the audience is clamoring to hear
from michael make sure that he's still
there
or if he's frozen in 1990 i'm still here
on his aol
56k modem dial michael we love you um
michael you're in charge of the pentagon
you've got access to
you know kamala harris our lead no no
joe biden
and uh you're able to do whatever what
do you think is warranted at this point
what do you think is warranted
uh to to kind of address these
legitimate concerns of eric on one hand
of the pilots uh alex and dietrich
heroes
um uh of the others um who are making
claims and of earnest individuals many
of whom are
listening and watching a thousand two
hundred people listening on watching
online right now
i mean what would you do what to what
level do we apply resources yeah go
ahead
yeah so you know of course if i
you know transported myself into the
pentagon and i would just release
everything
but that's because i'm on the outside
and i don't know what i don't know
that's on the inside and so it's like my
one of my concessions to conspiracy
theories that are true
is that when you get elected president
or whatever and you go and you see the
inside and you go oh
that's why we didn't pull the troops out
of iraq or that's why we didn't close
gitmo or that's why we can't close that
base in germany here
or whatever because you know i don't
know what they know
and so while it's easy for us on the
outside to say yeah just release the
information i mean come on
uh there could be reasons why they don't
i mean we didn't know about the stealth
bomber for
you know probably 20 years from the time
they were building it a really
revelatory book i read was um kelly's
book on
on the uh burbank located
um the skunk works where they designed
the u2 spy plane all that was going on
right here in los angeles i mean people
are driving by on the 134 freeway and
here's these spy planes being designed
nobody knew about it so
it's possible that you know it's
something like that on the
other hand it could be nothing and and
and uh it could be
something like we're all in the middle
of a like a psych experiment
one of these illusions with degraded
information you know like backward
masking of
playing rock songs backwards to see what
different people hear
or that remember a couple years ago that
dress that was golden
and white no it was blue and black and
you know people
looking at degraded information or
hearing degraded information
you know there's this pattern illusory i
call it patternicity where we tend to
find patterns in that
when you can't quite tell what's going
on and this is my sense about these
videos
and photographs is they're degraded just
enough we can't quite make it out you
have people like mick west you know
crunching the numbers could be this
here's some trigonometry
could be that okay somebody in the
pentagon knows
exactly what the videos mean why aren't
they telling us
this is the question and i don't know
you know again of course i if i
if i went in there i would release it
all but maybe if i went in there
i'd go oh okay now i see why we can't
agree with what's going on i think it
sounds like we're in agreement
like i'm not saying we should release
all data i'm saying
that you should either release the data
or
you should get the smart people
uh in one place as we have done in the
past
to say look we got a problem uh
we've got a blue on blue situation our
ufo enthusiasts have stumbled
on our top secret drone program or uh on
the knowledge that we've been
leapfrogged by
our adversaries or something like this
but
you don't just like not worry about it
and and why does why is mick west
anywhere in the story like the debunking
because he's though because he's the one
that's offered some actual hard
arguments for what the numbers mean on
the screen and what this is probably
as an alternative to the other two
hypotheses why did mick west ever
make west has got other things to do why
is he being put to this task
when presumably the experts who run
these uh these cameras and these planes
should be doing
i mean it's exactly what you said they
should and by the way
you know what you just said though is is
that the history
of the stealth bomber is a counter
example to the idea that all
information leaks instantly you know
in some sense is is that if well no my
point there was that it didn't
uh okay so this would be a counter
argument to what i usually say is the
skunk works
the skunk work was operating for decades
where you know those of us in the public
had no idea what was going on
so it is possible for secrets to be kept
at least for a while
yeah but in free societies of course is
much harder i mean the soviets had a
replica of the space shuttle called the
baron
identical in every way to one of our you
know highest performing vehicles ever
invented ever created
because we're an open society which puts
us at an informational disadvantage
i want to talk more about science and
scientists you guys are
are some of my favorite you know deep
thinkers about science we're living in
an unscientific age
but getting back to this uh this notion
that i talked about earlier
where on the cover of the new york times
you know pentagon says it's not ufo
it's not aliens but doesn't can't rule
it out either um
how do we talk to people eric you made
this point you know the risk of typing
right you didn't do that it was two
different headlines two different one
vision of the other yes and and and they
use their favorite
technique where they say something
that's defensible
to indicate something that they really
wish to convey to the public
so i think newsdiffs.org still exists
let's be very careful because every time
the new york times plays that particular
game it's important to catch them at it
and not pretend that
we're just reading a newspaper trying to
inform us right so that's why i want to
get to this core issue of the media and
who benefits
uh it's clear i don't think either one
of either one of you can refute the fact
that the media is benefiting
they have almost nothing to lose from
performing both sides of the story
not featuring you know skeptics on a 60
minutes show
not featuring you know a counter
narrative in the new york times article
uh but but how do we uh science-minded
people
how do we you know take this burden upon
us do we have to educate the peop
the population on what type one errors
are type two errors are
so that they'll answer eric's legitimate
question michael you know
if the risk is small but the cons you
know the probability is low
but the the impact factor of not picking
up the phone and calling eric
and i'll give out his phone number let
me just no no but uh but if the if the
risk is
incredibly high even if the chances are
low why aren't they calling him so
that's a legitimate thing that's type
one versus type two do we have to
educate the public and fight the battles
and
uncover what these things are where do
you come down on that
well yeah what's up i should
i should point out a book that just came
out may 3rd it's called the gray lady
winked
how the new york times is misreporting
distortions and fabrications radically
alter
history i haven't read the book yet i
want to get the author on the podcast uh
um you know he reaches back to the first
world war the second world war and how
you know the media is just not as
unbiased as we'd like them to be
including you know
all the news that's fit to print so yeah
it's um i don't know it's frustrating
you know when i hear stories like on
this particular topic and i can
see the mistakes that are made in the
media that are so
simple that they didn't have to make it
makes me wonder when i hear a story
about israel and palestine or russia and
civil rights violations in china or
something else i know
next to nothing about i can't help but
wonder well what kind of [ __ ] am i
getting
when i know they were wrong over here on
a simple subject like that
or just take the wuhan you know uh viral
clinic and all that's so much worse
right
i mean with with eric's pointed out and
with his brother as well
but you know really they've been on the
front lines of all this and now we're
seeing
for the first time in history zero
profit motive
instantaneous ability to disconnect huge
audiences you know
from from people who are legitimate
scientists trained individuals
and and basically u.s senators i mean
whether you agree with johnson or not
he's a u.s senator it's very unusual to
think about this taking away
a former president's ability to
communicate using some
now we're in this new era where
misinformation disinformation
even if it is incorrect information how
can you that can you check how can you
cross-check
and i just find it to be very dangerous
and i'm wondering what can we do about
it
uh as scientists or people who care
about this country
and and want to benefit the public as i
say i'm a public
employee i work for the state of
california at university of california
and i view it as my obligation
to give moral obligation to teach to the
public in words they can understand
but at what level do they do we you know
really hold the people accountable
that may be throttling accounts
information
followers videos etc so i mean eric what
do you what do you think is
is the less likely thing to happen is it
cancellation of this information
redaction
where are we going from here well we
don't know i mean
i have to admit to be blunt about it
that if we find out
that this was a
that there was really very little here
at all which is still i guess possible
because the the real data is i don't
know how they created this
uh this sort of haystack of nonsense at
this
to hide a needle of of something um
it's a very weird thing to call up sam
harris and have him say well it's
probably not aliens i mean
you know we have michael shermer here
and i don't
love the whole skeptic sort of vibe
because i think that these people uh the
best of us and i'm really glad to have
michael on this program
um are somewhat open
but you know recognize that it's very
unlikely
to be something of such earth-shattering
uh consequence i i i guess what i feel
like is
if they're chewing up the credibility of
everyone who can
hope to talk to the public i mean let me
just say this this is against the
backdrop of covid
where some of us had to say i'm not so
sure that we should be going to see
chinese new year
uh celebrations i'm not sure we should
be running the la marathon
i'm not sure that masks only magically
work for people who work in hospitals
and the rest of us shouldn't wear them
oh no no we have to wear them
in two weeks to flatten the curve made
no sense
what you're seeing is almost like a
constant attack on the credibility of
scientists with these
child-like official narratives and a
bunch of smart people who are held
hostage to them because in order to
challenge them results
in in censorship and expulsion and you
know just check out the comments
the the number of negative things that
you see scrolling by
so what you're seeing is you're seeing
the degradation of your scientific
uh class forced to deal with
inadequate information spending their
time in things
that are completely inefficient
because of the presence of centralized
narratives which are then
given the sort of blessings of the
institutions
and so what's what's ultimately going to
happen here is is that we're not going
to believe
almost anybody if we keep chewing
through this
the way we're doing uh i'm worried about
what happens when you can't go to sam
harris for sobriety or michael shermer
for sobriety
like i'm willing to swing at a bunch of
pitches in part because i came from a
family that went through the mccarthy
era and we found out
hey you know all those conspiracies a
lot of them were really true
because they were targeted on you and
your family right and so my bayesian
priors have to do with the fact that a
spy was sent against my own family
and when people say oh well you know
that's conspiracy talk well if we
if we had known that there was a spy
sent against our own family we wouldn't
have had our names read on national
television and that turned into peris
now would we
so you know in part i'm going to take
the prerogative of saying having been
betrayed by my government which i still
love and support but i also know that
they actually do conspire
right now the biggest danger we have is
the degradation
of trust in authoritative voices because
if to to sit inside of the institutions
means to depend on a paycheck that is
subordinate to a narrative
to sit outside is to be is to risk
becoming a crank
talking to the public the question is
why why are these people
having these conversations why are grown
people talking about little green men
and you know i just i have to tell you i
came off um
a a 3 000 person
call on twitter spaces because my
brother just got the second
strike as a an evolutionary theorist
talking about
whether or not ivermectin might be
effective against
covid and that whether or not novel mrna
vaccines might result in free-floating
spike proteins that would
have degradation at the level of
histology and cytology
and the idea that susan wojiki whoever
the hell she
is has the right to shut down biologists
and
even potentially the originator of the
mrna vaccine technology or one of the
innovators we have a
right now brian what we have to do is we
scientists
have to stop being employees we have to
have our professors
remember that they're not meant to be
the employees of the universities they
are the [ __ ]
owners and to subject people to implicit
bias testing which doesn't make any
sense
or to have somebody who can compute the
anomalous magnetic moment of the
electron subjected
to critical race theory to get them to
be more racist as a compulsory part of
employment
is a degradation of the condition of
american citizenship
and it is getting to the point where i'm
ready to pick up a torch and a pitchfork
and march on the chancellors of the uc
system
and other fine universities and say over
my [ __ ] dead body give us our data
give us our dignity get the hell out of
our labs get out of our classrooms
pretty pleased with sugar on top we've
created the prosperity of the country
and it is now time for you to remember
that
you don't have administrative rights
over me and if
if susan wojcicki starts to throw brett
weinstein off of youtube and if we get
thrown off because we're having a ufo
conversation
i'm going to have to ask whether our
society has been hijacked by a
geopolitical
strategic rival because this is
incredibly dangerous you don't chew
through the credibility
of your public-spirited smart people who
are technically capable of set
separating fact from fiction when given
proper data and autonomy
and subject them to being you know
supervised as if they're toddlers in the
nursery
michael any response from you about the
uh
listening listening to you is like it's
like martin luther
nailing the 95 theses on the door
i though he's got more theses you know i
call eric you know they say michael most
people are
if they're lucky they're broken clocks
they're right you know twice a day well
eric is my atomic my atomic clock so how
do you respond to all this michael
well so i guess well no i mean these are
all good points but the question is that
the way eric describes it
sounds very top-down very agent-prone
like there's somebody
kind of manipulating things i do wonder
if it's more
just bottom-up just the way the system
is designed
uh to end up with these kinds of
sensorial
uh actions against individuals or
universities becoming these
just kind of quagmires of bureaucracy
that can't seem to
stop from tripping over themselves i
don't know it's it's a hard call it
could be both
uh you know when you start pushing
critical race theory and
and you force people to take implicit uh
bias tests which have
we know don't work they do not measure
what you think you're measuring
we've shown that we ran columns seven
years ago from carol tavres
summarizing the meta studies on this
implicit race test
showing it doesn't work it's not
measuring implicit racism it's measuring
the speed
at which you respond to objects you're
familiar with or not familiar with
as a race or a gender or a size or
whatever it is
that you're doing so not to mention the
second part of that which is that
there's no evidence whatsoever that any
of these training programs do anything
to alter
people's attitudes to other people uh
unless it ends up making them even more
hostile
for having to go through these programs
trying to make me more racist
of course that's the problem you know
michael yeah you know if i say michael
what what are you doing for your
anti-anti-semitism
training there's no way he can answer
those questions right i can't answer it
right right
but but my point is this is this just
what big bureaucratic agencies end up
doing
just sort of kind of going along with
the media narrative
that you know black lives matter okay so
we got to do these following things i
don't want to do it but you know we
should do it
uh and that's kind of a bottom-up more
of a bottom-up explanation of what we're
going through
versus there's a handful of people at
the top kind of manipulating
us uh into going in this direction or
you know some combination of folks
there definitely is a handful i mean as
eric said you know eric susan majiki
when i was looking on there
the first thing i thought is like where
is they have a youtube medical team like
that's pretty awesome like you know
they're really looking out for it but
they don't right who are they what are
their credentials if
if that which can be refuted by
scientific evidence in the preponderance
of
we have a right for transparency and
accountability but then eric
can't they say to you you don't like it
you make your own platform
are you kidding me i mean i've been
through look
i don't mean to be there's a point at
which you have to appreciate that
the more i reiterate the same simplistic
points that
these are communications utilities and i
have an old joke
as a democrat should republicans be
allowed to use the roads
lord knows they could get up to
something conservative they might
actually meet
and they might have unfettered
conversations behind closed doors
so at some point when you're having a
conversation about should republicans be
able to use the roads to meet in an
unfettered
context having conversations in plain
political action
um you have to recognize that is not a
natural conversation that is an insane
conversation and i say that as a
democrat and
maybe even a progressive democrat uh
what we're talking about
all of us have enough years on us that
we remember a very different world
whatever this thing is you know as i say
everyone can prove to themselves by
doing any research that peer review is
not naturally a part of science
there is nothing that i am held up as a
crank for more than reminding people of
this truth
anyone who speaks a particular truth
becomes a crank in the eyes of the
narrative
this idea of calling vichy france france
is intrinsically a offensive to a
frenchman
uh sheltering in england plotting and
caucusing with the english
as to how to retake the nation of france
right now what we need to do is we need
to retake the nation of science
we need to take our own universities
back and
you know nobody believes in this stuff
who's smart we just all sit
around cowering like uh spineless
invertebrates
every time somebody threatens to call us
a name and what i'm trying to say is
brian you remember how to do physics you
remember how to do science you remember
how to communicate it
but what we don't do is we don't stand
up and say what jordan peterson said or
brett weinstein said or i say
we have to effectively say no moss you
can fire
me and as einstein said so brilliantly
and clearly
it is the obligation of the public
intellectual
to face financial ruin in prison
and if we're not willing to face
financial ruin and prison
to defend our values which provide the
prosperity and security
under which everyone else shelters
then we deserve to learn mandarin in our
schools in preparation for our future
now i personally would like to avoid
that i'd rather learn yiddish
or hindi but i think it's extremely
important to recognize
that this is the moment and you can't
slither away from your destiny forever
and you know kind of uh turning now to
some questions and uh from the audience
that people are asking
things you know that that i find are
legitimate again
i don't have the courage to put on a
uniform and fly in an f-18 i'd love to
do it it would be a lot of fun and i'm
hoping someday you have the courage to
talk about jeffrey epstein and the
intelligence community
do i yeah oh uh not to the level of
of you but i find it fascinating i'd
love to know more about it i think we've
covered i think
i have a one conspiracy limit per per
episode so
i would love to keep talking about it
but uh but no seriously i would like to
talk about it but obviously you you've
taken that issue
saying that you you can't ask the same
people to load up
on the wuhan lab leak jeffrey epstein
the madness of critical race theory
we've got these designated expendables
right
and they have to hit every single thing
to keep our society
from going in this extremely degraded
direction
do you think it's coming primarily from
the university michael you teach at
chapman
university um your classes are you know
renowned for their clarity for their
excellence and for their popularity um
you know what do you see on campuses do
you see us
being outmoded i've talked to eric about
this in the past are my days numbered
are our days numbered as
faculty when we can get instantaneous
access to information perhaps filtered
perhaps not
but um why learn from me when they can
learn from you know galileo or carl
sagan or
or whoever essential threats to all
these institutions including media and
academia
if it was just the knowledge then maybe
but the
uh value of the degree of having gone to
the brick and mortar
buildings at that particular ivy league
or
prestigious university that carries
weight according to the current
narrative that's what you're supposed to
do then
yeah then no we're our days are not
numbered
you know that's that will continue to
those autodidacts who don't care about
that
they just want to learn uh they can do
all that without going to the brick and
mortar buildings and
i think they will i just think the
levels of education will increase
dramatically
uh through you know internet sources and
so on without having to do that
but the universities will continue i
think it'll be interesting to see
you know the fallout from the pandemic
those universities
uh that were just kind of on the margins
financially anyway they may fold
uh much like a lot of restaurants that
close that just could never
reopen again that may happen uh remains
to be seen on that after they got their
ppp
loans you know and now they still can't
bounce back
you know we'll see in the next year or
so but the big ones you know they have
endowments they can last for years
being hammered financially and and so i
i think they'll continue
because we continue to overvalue
a college education i have to say even
though i'm
in the academy and i value it um
you know i just you don't need that to
have a good life
to have an enriched life or even to be
rich for that matter you don't have to
have a college degree
uh you know so i think you know that's
it in general i think we're going to
have to move away
from we're going to have to decouple uh
teaching
and uh and babysitting from research
though i think that it's very important
to recognize that the
babysitting that rockefeller university
the university of california san
francisco
perimeter institute the institute for
advanced study
are all effectively universities without
undergraduates
and in the case of the institute for
advanced study it's without graduate
students
not to say that you can't be on loan
from princeton the university
i think what we're coming to understand
is that the danger of housing weaker
subjects next to stronger subjects and
teaching next to research
with actually a tremendous hazard and
that what had previously
seen been seen as a symbiosis whereby
teaching and research
both aided each other in a particular
life
it is actually a tremendous risk when
the culture of academics has been lost
the culture of academics being lost has
to do with a bunch of different things
has to do with the eilberg amendment of
1976 the by don't buy
dole amendment of 1980 the immigration
act of 1990 the mansfield amendment of
the
late 60s early 70s i think that you have
to recognize
that something has marched
by making structural changes through
time
that leave us less free our professors
have less autonomy
they are now thought of as teachers um
they are subordinate students all of
this
is completely wrong to be called nas lug
um have made disastrous choices for our
elite research universities and
people have to recognize that there are
certain things that we have lied to the
public about or at least misled the
public about
the principal feature of a research
university is research
not the teaching of undergraduates and
until we actually
get to the point where we can say look
this was a funding model it has a lot to
do with a guy named vannevar bush and
something called the endless frontier
which was the blueprint post world war
ii until we were actually able to
educate our people in a non-fictitious
history of how we got to be this
powerful rich
and smart um we are going to assume that
americans have always been stupid
that in fact universities have always
been about teaching that all subjects
all professors are called scholars no
subjects are better than any others
that there's no relationship between the
military and our science that there's no
national character of science that just
actually um
you know sort of uh is something that we
fund with our taxpayer dollars but
all these things are for the good of the
planet that our
graduate students aren't students
they're workers the problem
is is that when we wake up in the
morning and we have a steady diet of
lies that can be detailed but there's no
place
inside of the establishment in the
institutions that is keeping an accurate
version of our history so imagine you're
living in a house
where the plans to the house are
completely fictitious
and every time you try to do remodeling
or you try to fix a water main or a
sewage pipe
you find out that the plans to the house
aren't actually corresponding to the
house at all that's the
problem with lying to yourself about
your own system
by the time the people who started the
lying
uh pass on and their great grandchildren
are manning the system the
the family no longer knows how the house
works
they live in it but they don't actually
understand how it was built and what
changes were made and that's where we
are right now is that we can't fix our
own problems because
nobody who's courageous enough to
actually
say what's true can get anywhere close
to being a provost or
president or a chaired professor
yeah we had a taste of that during
commencement season
in the various universities across this
great state of california
where where i'm privileged to teach but
again
we see as i see existential threats i
see
you know if you do a swot analysis we
have certain opportunities but the
opportunities seem to be
if you divide opportunities by threats i
i think the ratio is not looking very
good for my profession and
and as you look at i had on michael
saylor at the beginning of this year
and he was making public sailor academy
making an accredited university to teach
stem subjects now he's not going to
teach you know
as he says he's not going to teach you
know literature and uh
and french poetry but he's going to
teach stem you know can you learn to
code you can do stuff
online with some class-based cohort
stuff
i think it's it's interesting but i'd
like to know from you guys so we know
and we believe and i am worried actually
to be honest about you know
demonizing you know china and russia i
don't see how that serves
thermonuclear nations to to to view each
other not
xenophobic purely although that's evil
and wrong and racism is evil and wrong
we all agree
uh but but just to stipulate you know um
what what are the are there any bright
spots i mean i look at india i see them
very fast to adopt things like
cryptocurrencies i see them
extremely highly educated huge
population very mobile with 4g
5g these are incredibly you know is that
is that a bright spot where do you guys
see as a bright spot
amidst it or are we really gonna you
know potentially descend into a lot of
potential
you know xenophobia anti-anti-progress
narratives
i'll start with michael do you see any
bright spots for either addressing you
know
addressing the claims of this original
podcast or are just bright spots for
progress of humanity technology etc
given your
efficient market hypothesis theory
well i don't know how efficient it is
but well anti-progress has always been
around i mean you can you can go back to
the ancient greeks who
complained about uh you know the the
lack of progress and so on and
that's just human nature you know to
focus the negativity bias
drives us to notice negative things more
than positive things and if you're a
pundit
you get almost no kudos for saying
things are getting better
uh but but if you're a pundit that you
know constantly talks about the you know
at the end of the at the end of this and
the
in the demise of that then you get a lot
more hits
um and it's not that these things can't
happen it's just that they they rarely
do
most downfalls are more incremental than
than sudden not only but you know um
so again the you know the end of the
academy
you know probably not i could see you
know many positive shifts
everything eric said i think is a
concern uh you know how do you become a
dean
and then a provost and a president and
and so forth well
there's you know a lot of politicking
and i would want the job
in particular because that's like a real
job instead of getting to you know do
research and
and teach and all the fun stuff that we
went into this in the first place
uh and now it looks more and more like
um within the last year or so that if
you want those jobs you you absolutely
have to
to play the critical race theory card i
i
i just don't see any way around it at
least for the next year or two
many of us are pushing back on this but
you know it's hard to say if the
pendulum is going to swing
back any time soon i'm fond of telling
the story of my wife from germany
you know when she came here and we
started noticing these these trends
and she kept saying oh my gosh you know
i'm worried about our kid going off to
school and
getting indoctrinated and i kept don't
worry that pendulum is going to swing
back any day now and
it's just been getting worse and worse
and you know now the trans
stuff on top of the race stuff and
gender and
everything else and you know it does
seem like we've lost our collective
minds but on the other hand
there's a lot of us pushing back there's
a lot of organization like barry weiss's
new organization
fair uh and they're not the only ones
there's a dozen like that
and also organized groups like the
heterodox academy there's a dozen of
those of organized professors saying
we're not gonna you know we're mad as
hell and we're not gonna put up with it
anymore
now maybe they'll lose their jobs i
don't know but uh
in any case there's an if you know it's
the spiral of silence problem to break
the spiral of silence
you just have to have enough people
speak out at just a tipping point might
be three percent five percent
of people stand up and say no and that
releases the next 10 percent to say
yes i was worried about the same thing i
was afraid to say anything and then 20
more and then 30 percent and pretty soon
you have a majority that say yeah
yeah now we're not going to do this
anymore and you know that's how it
happens
and so i i i'm hoping that that unfolds
in the next
i don't know five years or so um i can't
say it's going to turn around the next
six months though
eric what do you see is any optimism i
mean anything you've changed your mind
on
anything to be uh to not go away and and
hit the sauce like i normally do after
we chat
tipple to make me not tipple is that my
japanese whiskey no i never gave you the
bite
i only have water i gotta but this is
ruach
but uh not scotch unfortunately oh we're
together
um look i mean it's a it's an odd
question i mean i
i just people say well don't complain do
something i do
and i like one thing is is that um
so far as i can tell people stopped
trying to
unify physics and
geometric unity is in a live attempt
waiting for somebody to engage it
to push beyond both
the einsteinian paradigm and the
standard model paradigm
that's a direct attempt to
come up with new physical fields new
forces
to question the actual standard model as
it is
there are two generations not three and
there's a reason you're being fooled
about the third
the world is not chiral it's emergently
chiral
so in essence attempting to learn your
own source code
is you know we didn't really get to the
point of saying
which would have been responsible but
terrifying assume that it's aliens
then what yeah right so if it is aliens
which has to be a leg on the decision
tree the question is how would aliens
make the most sense
so one of the things that i've been
trying to point out is is that we always
talk about extra dimensions as if they
are extra spatial dimensions
but in my theory i believe that there
are additionally
either four or six temporal dimensions
the ability to hack both time and space
at the
level of dimension is not clear to me as
to whether they're accessible
but imagine for example that you could
enlarge rulers to shrink distances
i'm excited about the idea of junking
this
fetishization of mars and uh and
and the moon and taking a look at the
night sky
and asking the question if einstein
theory is only an effective theory
uh as indicated by the existence of
schwarzschild
and initial singularities in our model
then wouldn't it be amazing if we could
get beyond
that as an effective theory and do to
einstein what einstein did to newton and
recover him as an approximation
and find out whether a change in in our
understanding and actually getting to
the source code
would unlock something new conversely
the level of markets
i've put forward uh a field theoretic
um you know approach to economics
together with my wife
and i'm delighted to see that stephen
wolfram uh seems to be in the process
of discovering that inflation uh is a
physical theory and that holonomia uh
looks like the beaumarinov effect
and he will soon i believe rediscover
our work which will be
tremendously exciting as his pr is
somewhat better than mine
so the issue of finding excitement
with respect to
new biological applications new crypto
applications i think distributed
computing is incredibly exciting
um if you supplement bitcoin fixes this
with things like academic freedom fixes
this or geometric unity or gauge theory
fixes this
uh those those are memes uh
unfortunately to the kitties in the uh
bitcoin maximalist community who just
like to cause trouble for the most part
but to be honest those guys really have
a point and a soul and they're trying to
do great things i think that what
happened in el salvador may be a
disaster
but the idea of a of a country
adopting a cryptocurrency uh that it
does not control
to try to bring fiscal discipline and
freedom is tremendously exciting
given how bad el salvador has been in
terms of
all sorts of governance problems one of
the interesting questions is does
bitcoin fix this
so i think that what you have to say is
ar and vr are tremendously exciting
uh personalized medicine is tremendously
exciting
space travel temporal uh
and spatial dimension hacking is
exciting
i think that all sorts of things that we
could be doing
would be great the really interesting
thing is is that
sooner or later somebody with
probably 11 figures of wealth and up is
going to watch one of these pro
programs and say you know there's
only so much i can do with one more
effing lamborghini
why don't we try to actually do
something that moves the needle
and give a small number of the people
trying to push the frontier
the freedom over their lives that we
take for granted
or we can just go uh you know and put
one more private plane in the fleet one
more
mega yacht in the mediterranean and just
watch the whole thing crumble and burn
so what my real hope
eventually is is that doing this at
scale
we are eventually going to find somebody
who wants to do something very different
with money
and so far as i know none of our
billionaire class not one billionaire
is really interested in rebuilding the
stuff that is now crumbling
and so you know if you're out there and
if you're watching this
there's a tremendous amount of stuff to
do
some of us will pick up shovels some of
us will pick up torches and pitch forks
but somebody else should pick up their
checkbook and get us the hell out of
here so that we can actually
do something even more interesting than
this amazing podcast
which i've really enjoyed me too and
that's actually
eric y invited michael you talked about
11 figures of wealth and
michael's here yeah yeah right yes
retail i'm getting my bikes do you need
michael
yes yeah here's my checkbook how much
how much is it that you need exactly how
many zeros on that check uh
it's just one how many is that yeah you
should have said this one
does he does he really need another all
right guys i'm gonna i'm gonna sign off
and go have gage theory uh whiskey
great this has been wonderful michael
thank you so much eric thank you so much
as usual just point to people i've had
interviews with both these gentlemen
wonderful conversations over the years i
hope to have many more with you guys i
always enjoy
the conversation and uh look if you are
interested
i have a lot of videos about aliens i'm
sorry to say this is my last video i'm
gonna do
i have one uh in the can that i did with
uh seth strosstech
but um i've had a very fascinating uh
ride
learning about from different signs
doing what the military calls a red team
approach you get
people on the best sides on both sides
and you and you hopefully come to some
notion of truth but now this expedition
is over as we wait all with our uh
collective attention drawn to what gets
released in the next couple weeks i
am dubious but i i hope i'm hoping for
the more
fantastical because that'll ensure job
security for me forever for now
please give a subscription to michael's
channel skeptic
on youtube please subscribe to eric's
channel also on
uh on itunes both these guys leave them
reviews leave them ratings it really
helps us grow our channels and grow the
audience with the algorithm
that is continually working to defeat us
anyway i'm brian keating your fearful
host here
at uc san diego uh co-director of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination stay tuned for some
really cool videos that i have coming up
about uh string theory loop quantum
gravity
uh polarization and also inflation in
the multiverse and god
why are so many physicists talk about
god we'll get michael and eric back on
for that
guys love you guys all right wonderful
night thank you all for joining
good night guys bye-bye bye eric
i see you again see you as always
[Music]